elle vous de newton merci d'être parmi
nous ce soir
alors si je comprends bien vous êtes
plutôt un homme à femmes mais ce que je
veux savoir c'est pourquoi vous les
choisissez pour les photographier riche
et célèbre
le jeu c'est pas ce fait comme ça ils
sont pas tous riches et célèbres
ben plus les plupart en général quand
louis m'a vu paloma picasso on a vu des
comédiennes ce qui en a une que vous
n'avez jamais photographié alors que
vous auriez aimé n'avoir donc oui il ya
une femme que me fascine à la partie la
journaliste
oui et j'ai eu une merveilleuse lettre
des lacets excuser parce que peut-être
qu'un jour je vais réussir une
comédienne il ya beaucoup que vous
n'ayez pas photographier trois mois il y
avait eu avec moi j'ai déjà beaucoup de
gaz actrice formidable
vous êtes les portraits de femmes depuis
presque trente ans maintenant vous avez
vu l'évolution de la femme est ce que
vous êtes pro du compte de son évolution
aussi dans sa façon d'être et dans son
physique même beaucoup spécialement en
france quand je suis arrivé ici le fin
d'année 50 tous les mannequins parisien
qui est tout petit 1 m 65 13 minutes
maintenant ce sont deux des amazones et
les mêmes qu'à parisiens sont plus
vraiment française non plus il ya pas
mal de fois de plus en plus j'ai les
françaises et les mesures vont bien bah
rien passe sous un mètre 75 de plus
petite taille
on peut se servir et laure lesquels vous
préfériez le plus grand des murs vous
êtes un photographe de mode très connue
très c'est là d'ailleurs je parlais
votre livre avec deux ou trois
photographes cette semaine tout le monde
sait qu'il va sortir on l'attend c'est
un événement je vais vous demander
bon après la mode qu'est ce qui vous
amusera qu'est ce que vous aimeriez
faire parce que vous avez fait le tour
du problème quand j'ai arrêté la mode
tout à fait parce que j'ai fait pour
presque 50 ans j'ai commencé comme
apprenti quand j'étais très jeune et
maintenant j'ai fait beaucoup de
portraits et les nus j'aimerais une
exposition de tenues en mois de novembre
à paris c'est dingue et un plomb et ce
sont tous des photos que j'ai fait cette
année sont tous
nouvelle balle en dehors du nu puisque
oms est plus demain de 7 kw à dos parce
que j'ai par le fait un peu de paysages
qu'ils y ça c'est très difficile
j'aimerais revenir à ça mais les porter
ça sur un thème sont sans fin parce
qu'il ya tellement de gens merveilleux
et un dans le monde
dans votre livre j'ai observé qu'il y
avait un certain nombre de photos d'être
merveilleuse comédienne française kg
revoteront qu'ils peuvent tous vos
jetons dessus elles suivent in c était
votre mascotte un peu oui j'ai commencé
à photographier chaleur 173 voix des
photos et j'ai plus de parité j'ai fait
beaucoup de photos d elle et j'ai d'une
femme fascinante elle parle déjà un même
langue que vous au bout il qu'elle ait
pas très belle anglaise elle est
vraiment française par choix
oui parisienne et la voulait cette femme
répond non vous l'avez vu évoluer parce
que vous pouvez changer de vie zone
rouge mais bien sûr que ce qu'une femme
très intelligente et c'est la femme
intelligente qui est voulu
les femmes qui restent toujours pareil
j'ai pas très impatient et très bien la
femme change vous les suivez vous assure
encore longtemps
j'espère merci middleton